experts are unraveling the full scope of
covet 19's long-term implications and
the latest finding is an increased risk
of a serious chronic condition people
who were infected with covet that they
had about 17 to 22 percent higher risk
of developing diabetes compared to those
who did not have coving this isn't isn't
for study to examine exam a link between
the two diseases but it is one of the
largest looking at more than 629
000 people we found that one in 20
people who are living with diabetes
during this time that could be related
to their covet infection researchers say
more study is required because at this
point they don't know if covid-19 causes
diabetes diabetes experts have a few
theories about why more diabetes cases
were found in people who had covet 19.
one possibility could be that the kobit
19 virus might be affecting the pancreas
which makes insulin and that is one of
the ways that the body manages sugar
levels and and prevents it from getting
diabetes another hypothesis is that
people who were diagnosed with Cova 19
were overall more likely to get sick and
then be followed by doctors they're more
likely to be hospitalized and they're
more likely to be seen by doctors over
the next year or two which is more
opportunities to get a test for diabetes
so it's possible that infection just
might have increased the ascertainment
the detection of diabetes more
frequently compared to non-infection
while many questions linger researchers
say the link gives doctors more clues
about what to watch for long term and
that could help us to Think Through how
we monitor people and how we could
advise people in terms of reducing their
risks Catherine Ward Global News Toronto